[Musique]
d'après ce que l'on sait la catastrophe
s'est déroulé très vite les campeurs du
grand bornand n'ont pas vraiment eu le
temps de réagir la suite d'un violent
orage
une rivière le borgne est sortie de son
lycée transformées en torrents d'eau
boueuse et a déferlé sur le camping
brutalement le dernier bilan jeudi
bienne est encore provisoire fait état
de 19 morts et de trente disparus
françois chante et on a d'abord cru à
une tornade
hier en fin d'après midi un orage d'une
extrême violence a fait brutalement
monté les eaux d'un petit taureau au
moins de dix minutes
une coulée de boue de 20 mètres de large
s'est formé emportant tout sur son
passage
le camping du grand bornand se trouve
sur les rives du petit torrent en
quelques instants voitures caravanes
tentes tout est emportée par le torrent
dévastateur les pans entiers d'une
petite route située au dessus du camping
se sont écroulés tous ces produits si
rapidement les vacanciers n'ont pas eu
le temps de trouver refuge
certains se sont calfeutrés dans leur
caravane d'autres ont escaladé les
parois qui borde le camping pour
échapper à la coulée de boue
et il était il est impossible de prévoir
c'est un peu l'équivalent de tout un
peuple qui font de ternate c'est
absolument impossible de primaire cet
orage cette soupe d'eau et toutes les
conséquences qui en découlent et
d'ailleurs la meilleure des preuves dans
les communes voisines sur le bas de la
vallée bien la route départementale a
été emporté sur sur plusieurs centaines
de mètres on la rend km rapport est
importé la route était coupée à
plusieurs endroits
alors que la route se trouve
départementale donc existe depuis début
du siècle
très rapidement un plan de secours
d'urgence est déclenché la préfecture de
haute savoie organise les secours
en tout quatre cents sauveteurs sont sur
place pour tenter de retrouver les
nombreux disparus
deux cent vingt sapeurs pompiers
plongeurs ou pour tâche de sonder la
rivière
à l'heure qu'il est on a pu dénombrer 19
morts et 20 disparus
madame monsieur bonsoir la nature en
folie a coûté la vie à 20 personnes et
28 autres sont portées disparues c'était
hier soir en haute savoie un orage
terrible des torrents qui se précipite
et la boue qui emporte tout un terrain
de camping sur place voici thierry
calmette et yens gicquel les campeurs
venait de se réfugier dans leur caravane
au bord du torrent pour s'abriter de
l'orage en quelques minutes une coulée
de boue a pris à revers le camping du
born emportant 85 caravane sur son
passage ce soir lourd bilan au moins 22
morts plus d'une vingtaine de disparus
c'est carcasse déchiquetée se trouve à
plus d'un kilomètre du camping ce couple
de rescapés fouilles dans les restes de
leur voiture pour retrouver les clés de
leur appartement
il faut s'y promontoire
une vingtaine de personnes qui sont
restées isolées avec des courants et des
vagues de deux mètres de haut un amas de
caravanes à les protéger en amont puis
par hélicoptère en par une sortie il y
en a et notre corps qui sont restés dans
les arbres un père et le fils ont les
épaules trop poreuse entre les caravanes
avec parfois leurs occupants ont dévalé
le lit du torrent à trois kilomètres du
camping un essieu de la tôle la route
effondrée
des vestiges du désastre les secours
sont arrivés très vite avec des moyens
importants
deux hélicoptères 400 gendarmes des
sapeurs pompiers mais le plus souvent il
ne retrouve que des corps peu d'espoir
de récupérer des survivants dans le lit
du torrent dans ce camping privé du
grand bornand
y at il eu négligence aucun élément ne
permet d'établir qu'il y'avait
accumulation de matériaux ayant créé un
barrage artificiel car il ya un barrage
naturel par l'accumulation de ces
matériaux et il n'y avait pas de retenue
tôt dans cette volée ce soir dans
l'église du village transformée en
chapelle ardente
les corps des victimes se font de plus
en plus nombreux victime d'une
catastrophe naturelle comme on dit un
plan de recensement des risques majeurs
est en cours dans la région
en ce qui concerne la commune du grand
bornand il n'était pas achevée mais la
préfecture avait écarté tous les risques
d'inondations ici la dernière inondation
remonte à 1936 était il possible de
prévoir que 50 ans après le torrent de
bordes charest plus de 50 fois son débit
moyen
identifier celui de disparus il ya place
pour une lueur d'espoir à leurs charges
des appels qui ont de moins en moins
deux cents attendus
une interrogation comment ce terrain de
camping at il pu être balayés par la
boue en quelques minutes un dojo rage
les affluents du coran dont chennai aux
fibres aussi dans le massif des aravis
c'est normal il ya eu des précédents en
1870 la fin 36 mais voilà la subtile
hier le maire savait qu'il lui le seul
camping privé jeté la clé d'un rapport
final la délégation respect
[Musique]